ah
encontramos a artur y kiril en la ruta
hacia el este de ucrania han huido de
boston el ciudad al noroeste de aquí
donde se encuentra un estratégico
aeropuerto y buscan un lugar seguro en
el que resguardarse pero no es fácil
hurts estofán es difícil encontrar un
sitio seguro en el cual vivir
safeplace place to live
sol
yo lo he encontrado pero mucha gente no
lo puede encontrar y no sabe qué hacer
and find puesto live and done nuevo bots
todo aterrorizado por lo que han vivido
artur y kiril quiere retomar el camino
rápidamente para esquivar los atascos
kilométricos en las zonas rurales
alejado de los bombardeos el éxito de
personas es masivo
en la abarrotada estación de este grupo
de mujeres están luchando hacia polonia
cuentan que han viajado solas porque los
hombres no pueden abandonar el país por
una decisión del gobierno craneano a
causa del conflicto
en astún papel nuestra casa fue
bombardeada y las ventanas y puertas
quedaron hechas trizas
nos salvamos solo porque no estábamos en
casa por eso estamos vivos tuvo
mamocracia esta lenta mujer
las bombas también aterrorizado por días
a andy un estudiante nigeriano quien
acaba de llegar de schumi gracias a un
corredor humanitario
estoy intentando salir de aquí poder
dormir y ver qué hacer luego como next
artur kiril angélica y andy son los
rostros de una crisis humanitaria que
crece cada día y se asuma más de 2
millones de desplazados ucranianos en
unas dos semanas